قد تستغرب من الموضوع مصطلح الا انجابيه
فاذا كان جديدا بالنسبه الي فهو ببساطه
يعني رفض احضار مواليد جدد الى الحياه
انتشرت هذه الفكره في الغرب طبعا اساسا
لحتى وصلت لاحقا الى بعض الدول العربيه ثم
انعكست ايضا على صفحات التواصل الاجتماعي
وتحت عناوين متعدده
ومتابعوها هم بالالاف حمله شباب ضد
الانجاب مجموعه
مغاربه لا انجابيون ايضا مجموعه اخرى صفحه
ضد التناسل كذلك مجموعه اخرى يجتمع فيها
كل هؤلاء الذين يسعون لتغيير فكره الزواج
من اجل تكوين اسره الى زواج دون اطفال
بعضهم مشاهدينا يرى انجاب اطفال هو امر
غير اخلاقي واخرون يرون ان ظروف المديه
والمعيشيه لا تحتمل فريق ثالث ايضا يعتقد
انه كلما زاد اعداد او عدد سكان الارض
كلما قلت الموارد
ليش انت وشو هو السبب اللي بخليك تقرر انه
انت ما بدك تنجل طيب خليني اقول الانجاب
بالنسبه لي هو جريمه في حق من قررنا جلبه
الى هذا العالم المتحارب من اجل ان يعيش
الصراعات الانسانيه التي نعيشها جميعا في
الوقت الراهن
الانجاب
يعني انا علشان انجب اصلا يعني انا انا
بستغرب دايما سؤال بيوجه الي انا ومن مثلي
انت ازاي مش عايز تخلف الحقيقه ان السؤال
المناسب هو ازاي الناس عندها القدره على
على انها تنجب ما هي الاسباب والدوافع
القيمه التي التي تؤدي بالناس الى الانجاب
من الاساس لماذا وهل يمكن انه يكون هذا
القرار يعني غير صائب يا سيدتي يعني حرب
عالميه ولو حرب عالميه تانيه وبشائر او
تنبؤات اعتذر تنبؤات بحرب عالميه ثالثه
وحرب نوويه شامله فضلا عن حروب العصور
القديمه كل هذا لم تنتهي به البشريه هل
ستنتهي بفكره
يعتنقها مجموعه قليله جدا جدا من سكان
كوكب الارض هذا امر ليس منطقي طيب خليني
اسال الدكتوره علي لانه الوقت ضيق وضحت
هذه النقطه دكتور علي بهنسي الاستشاري
النفسي يعني واحد مش عاوز يخلف ولكن ممكن
يتجوز
تستقيم ازاي ليه دلوقتي الجزء في تكوين
شخصيه الانسان او الجزء النفسي في تكوين
الانسان في جزء مهم جدا اسمه
اللي هو الابويه شخصيه الانسان في المدرسه
التحليليه البسيطه بتعتبر في جزئين كل
الناس عندهم عندهم وده جزء مكون رئيسي في
التقسيم التحليلي النفسي لشخصيه الانسان
هل نقدر نستغني عن الجزء ده في تكوين هو
انه احنا ليش نجلب الدم على هذا الطفل
القادم الى الحياه ما هو في المقابل انا
علشان اتمنى هذه الفكره لازم يكون لي سبب
ليها السبب بتاع الفكره ديت الرهابنا
يستغنون عن الاطفال هذا القطاع لعباده هذا
انقطاع لعباده وضع اخر مختلف
بالظبط
بالظبط كده علشان اقدر انا كانسان استغنى
عن ان انا اكون اب او اكون مشاعر الابوه
او ما تكتملش الجزء النفسي عندي فلازم
يكون الدافع في غايه القوه
ولازم يكون
الفكره او المشاعر اللي عندي مشاعر مسيطره
علشان ما اكملش النمو النفسي